just five and five though in those games
but they win it by 10 and they are in to
the uh inseason tournament semifinals
against either the Lakers or the Suns I
tell you what when you watch when you
watch this Pelican team and you see
Alvarado who's only played what in eight
games now Trey Murphy's only played in a
couple of games now uh McCullum is back
in that mix Shaq this is a team that uh
that has got some depth and and some
tent they have dep Talent a lot of
potential uh especially with alverto and
uh you know the other guy they play they
they play very very aggressive you know
once Zion learns how to put his imprint
on the game dominate I don't use that
word but once he learns how to dominate
the games he not good enough to just
have good games he has to make an impact
on the game once he learns to dominate
on a consistent basis they will be a
dangerous team right now they're they're
going to be up and down uh you know
Ingram has always been Ingram he's
always play like that I like Valen
chunes but I agree with Chuck Zion is
the wild card once he learns how to make
an impact on the game like I said early
and dominate dominate dominate more than
six rebounds more than 25 26 point and
play with Force every time Sprint easy
buckets dunks jump hooks right now he's
a little too uh inconsistent for me
right
now go ahead Kenny I think the
inconsistency well he well first of off
he is super skilled in terms of ball
handling for his size his uh his touch
around the rim and his ability to pass
and find people it it's high level the
what happens when you're not in
basketball shape you you're just not in
the plays that you should be in so
instead of sprinting back where he
because of his athleticism he could have
blocked the shot he he can't get there
because of his uh not being in the
proper basketball shape sometimes you
can't Dart into the passing Lane and get
the Steal you can't get the deflection
which causes the offense to stagnate on
the other team so he's missing out on
plays that he would be he would make a
significant impact instead of just
making the impact only on the offensive
end I think that he can make the impact
on other places and when he gets in
basketball shape and he's getting there
he's in much better shape obviously than
he was in the before because but he's
still probably I would say 30 days 45
days away from being what we've seen him
be in college or or coming into the
league well
Ernie how many NBA teams got three
Allstars not many all three of those
guys are Allstars so they ahead of
everything what I love what Brandon
Ingram said he talked about Alvarado
herb Jones he even mentioned Marshall
man those guys play with tremendous
energy especially Alvarado and that's
what you want your bench to do you're
not play paying your bench to win you
games you're paying them like hey when
we go to you guys keep the lead or keep
it right there like uh so their bench is
terrific the problem with Zan
is he's playing with two All Stars so
he's not going to get the ball as much
like some games he going to get 30 but
some games he going to get 18 but when
you get 18 you got to get 14 rebounds
cuz you have to well like I say when I
when you AR G get the ball every time
you're like okay how can I make an
impact on the game him averaging six
rebounds a game is ridiculous he should
be a double double guy and Underdog told
me earlier he's only had two games you
say he's played 17 games he's 18 today
he's only had two double doubles that's
ridiculous with his a talent level
that's
crazy